president biden is hosting a call with
u.s allies today on the standoff with
russia meanwhile secretary of state
anthony blinken has agreed to meet with
russia's foreign minister late next week
as long as there is no invasion blinking
gave a blistering speech at the u.n
about the crisis fujijang is at the
white house with more on these
diplomatic efforts ouija good morning
good morning vlad and good morning to
everybody despite russia's escalation
president biden has not ruled out the
possibility of that diplomatic path cbs
news has just learned that defense
secretary lloyd austin is set to speak
with russia's minister of defense
sometime today it is part of this
administration's full court press to
find an alternative to war
president kamala harris and secretary of
state anthony blinken are in germany for
a security summit and the stakes
couldn't be higher
president biden warned that the threat
of a full-scale russian invasion remains
quote very high they have not moved any
of their troops out they've moved more
troops in the russian military has built
up nearly 160 thousand troops around
ukraine the president pointed to another
sign of an imminent invasion accusing
russia of attempting to justify it by
staging a smaller attack ukraine and
russian-backed rebels blamed each other
for the thursday bombing of a
kindergarten in eastern ukraine blinken
told the united nations security council
there may be more to come
it could be a fabricated so-called
terrorist bombing inside russia
the invented discovery of a mass grave
a staged drone strike against civilians
or a fake
even a real
attack using chemical weapons and russia
made another move expelling the u.s
embassy's second in command from moscow
still the administration has not ruled
out a diplomatic de-escalation let me be
clear
i am here today
not to start a war
but to prevent one
its written response to the security
proposals that the u.s made last month
the russians warned that they might be
forced to use military might if the u.s
and nato do not agree to keep ukraine
out of the defense alliance forever
which is something they have already
said is not an option michelle
and as you said the standoff continues
thank you